do you have children I assume I do four
of them okay so that's I have three uh
your children are much younger obviously
the ten nine six and 17 months okay so
you're young Jody right now they're not
fully formed as you can't tell whether
they're gonna be superstar athletes or
whatever and right now you have them
under your control more or less when
they get to be teenagers a little more
challenging when they're young adults
you know they may call you back they may
not call you back so raising children is
the most difficult thing to do in life
interesting wow more than marriage
tougher than marriage
yes because you're dealing with more
than one person typically you're dealing
with three or four different children or
if you have four children and it's very
difficult also marriage is complicated
but but children is the heart hardest
thing to do is raising children who are
happy and successful and that's very
hard to do now
um when you're wealthy and reasonably
prosperous it's even harder because I
had no money growing up and I realized
I'm going to get anywhere I got to work
hard yep if you have money the tendency
is to give your kids money make it easy
for them and in the end you're probably
hurting them
um so it's not easy to raise raise kids
when you have a lot of money or your
prominent you're successful very
difficult to do that I think so so
there's a lot of context a lot of
questions right there so one I've heard
a lot of different formulas about
happiness what's yours and two how do
you do it with the kids when you do have
money at what point is it important to
manage expectations with them well with
my children they're well educated they
went to Harvard Stanford and Duke and so
forth so they got a good education but
they um you know they always challenge
every child has challenges no perfect
child so you always have challenges and
a parent has to figure out how to deal
with child health challenges or whatever
they might be I would say
um if I said to my children I'm giving
you each a billion dollars and they got
a billion dollars would they make them a
better person I don't know
um very rarely do you inherit a billion
dollars and all of a sudden you win a
Nobel Peace Prize or something like that
people that change the world often come
from Blue Collar backgrounds or middle
class backgrounds the people that change
the world and the ones you really want
to admire are people that really came
from backgrounds probably like yours and
mine
should we give me the formula for
happiness
well my formula for happiness is is
basically of course being reasonably
healthy that's good because you don't
want to have health problems but but
basically having a relationship with um
other people that you that you find uh
satisfying particularly your children
secondly
um it's giving back to other people
um generally when people help other
people they feel better about themselves
uh people who don't help anybody else
probably don't feel that well that great
about themselves there are many people
who are very wealthy extremely wealthy
they don't give away very much and I
don't think they're very happy people
um generally giving away money or your
time your time is more valuable than
your money you can make more money you
can't make more time I think people that
do that feel happier about themselves
and as a general rule of thumb I
encourage people to do philanthropic
things which I include meaning giving
your time and your volunteering uh
things not just money
um people that I I isolated that sit in
their house and just count their money
and big build big houses and count how
big their boat is I'm not sure they're
that happy the most tortured Souls I
know are extremely wealthy people the
happiest people I know are often people
who have no money now that doesn't mean
you don't want to have any money but you
have to make sure you understand what
money is all about it's designed to make
you I think have a better life but
you're gonna have a better life if you
you help other people now I tell people
all the time when I'm making
philanthropic or pitches when you when
you're trying to give away when you give
away money give away time help other
people you'll feel happier about
yourself happier people live longer
grumpy people don't live as long also
there's a special place in heaven
reserved for people that do this now
people laugh when I say that but I say
why would you want to take a chance and
I'm wrong I could be right you don't
know you sound like a pastor saying that
that's the pastor's uh close right so um
you know in life as you get older I'm
obviously older than you you know what
you do worry about as you get older is
your health because we all know uh you
know that people don't don't have the
same lifespan when I was younger I used
to ask my parents why do you read the
obituary pages and they say well I want
to see who I knew that died I read the
obituary Pages now because my friends
are dying um you know people younger
than me are dying I'm saying how come
I'm lucky that I'm not dead and my
friends are are gone in some cases so
you know when you read the obituary
pages and you see somebody 45 55 65
dying what do they they do wrong how do
they have such bad fortune so you know
every day is a blessing in a sense that
you know you're trying to do something
useful with your life and hopefully uh
you know you have a long time to go to
make your kids uh you know appreciate
what you've built but in the end raising
four children is not you said marriage
is easier than kids okay for me uh uh
I'm not going to make it clear marriage
half the people that get married are
divorced so it obviously isn't that easy
I don't make it sound like it's easy
yeah but but I guess I guess the
question I want to ask from is the
following uh did your wife help you like
did you and your wife build a business
together was or was it always separate
all right okay but people who build
business with their partner uh their
smart their spouse I think it's that can
be done but sometimes when you're
working together with somebody 24 hours
a day it's a little challenging because
you have you know there's always
tensions and sometimes I've noticed that
husband wife businesses don't work as
well so okay so so for you you've seen
it not work if they're working together
but you've also seen it not work if it's
separate because to me the way I would
see it as a push back and you know say
no I don't agree with you if your wife
working on this business with the
insurance business we did everything
together she's got office upstairs and
first time we shared an office together
she said babe we can't be in the same
office you're too loud so we put and we
literally had our office complete
opposite ends uh and then I saw a lot of
my friends who made money
and they built the business separately
it's as if the more time was going by
interest was you know separating and
there were no running for the same cause
except for the kids the only thing that
was in common was kids and then
eventually it went from being a wife to
being a roommate that's what I saw a lot
of times with people who were doing two
different businesses now you have more
wisdom and I than I do that's why I'm
asking your gray hair you don't have any
gray hair I have some of it my wife I
was standing there
wow
Jimmy Carter whom I work in the white
house he's been married 75 years
the only time he came close to getting
divorced was when he and his wife agreed
to write a book together they found out
they couldn't they couldn't they
couldn't do it they ultimately gave the
publisher the money back and they didn't
they didn't do it or at least to write
the book together it was uh so that was
the only time he said he ever got close
to getting divorced so you know working
together with a partner and a spouse can
be wonderful at times when things work
out but when there's problems who gets
blamed and who you know it's I don't
want to get into the whether it's easier
to raise children or be um uh marriage
but uh raising children my point is is
very difficult and you've got four
children you're going to be with them
they're their father their whole life
and I ask people when do you stop
worrying about your children I think
when they turn 60 or 70 you probably
stop worrying about them but the rest of
your life you're every time you get a
call late at night you're gonna for my
child you're gonna wonder what went
wrong and they're out later than you
wanted to be out what are they going to
do you know when they're one and two and
three years old they look Angelic when
they're 15 and 16 and 17 and they're
trying to do something you don't want to
do not so Angelic David why why do so
many billionaires marriages not end up
working out uh I talked to one of my
pastors who says look I just want to
tell you this I don't know what it is
but when you become a billionaire things
change kids change not kids change
relationships change family looks at you
differently friends look at you
differently you have to be kind of
careful on how to maneuver through those
things when you're making that kind of
money is it the fact that more
billionaires are getting divorces or is
it the fact that billionaires are more
known and people know them and we notice
more when they get divorces than the
average person gets what's the latter
actually there's a higher divorce rate
among people who are blue collar workers
really a harder very interesting for
higher divorce rate wow
um they have more challenges as well but
billionaires when they make a lot of
money how do you make a lot of money
it's not just sitting around you're
tough you're you're driven and when you
take those qualities and you bring it to
your marriage it's a little more
challenging you say to your wife look
I'm a brilliant person I made a billion
dollars what did you contribute today to
the marriage and you know that can tend
to you know be offsetting sometimes
there are billionaires that that uh that
you know have reasonably good marriages
my observation but as we've known some
of the wealthiest men in our country
have recently gotten divorced so it's
not that easy to be married when you're
that rich yeah it I I'm sure listen
marriage is already hard letter on out
adding all the other components to it
but uh you know maybe there's an element
and again I don't know where you go
outside where you know the whole scene
where uh everybody says oh my God it's
this look who it is oh my goodness oh my
God cannot believe it and you come home
hey babe can you take out the trash you
know what I'm saying like do you know
who I am like well there is that element
yeah the you know for example when
you're you're in the office you're
treated like a god you're everybody
works for you when you come home you're
not a God you got to go pick out you
know take out the garbage or deal with
the kids change the diaper whatever it
might be and people say I don't have to
do this I'm a billionaire I'm a
multi-billionaire but you know sometimes
it works sometimes it doesn't so what
all the craziness taking place I believe
future looks bright if you believe
future looks bright get your latest
Future looks bright hat of valuetainment
it says future looks bright here future
looks bright here we got them in white
we got them in Black we got them in red
our black on black sold out these are
about to sell out if you haven't ordered
one yet we had a person in Michigan but
one then he bought three then when those
three people were in the office they had
to order 58 of them because people
wanted the future looks bright hat
especially during times like this
because ain't nobody's saying future
looks bright toward your future looks
bright hat click over here and to watch
the entire podcast click here take care
everybody
foreign
[Music]